Tatum has it Smith defending drives the
lane gets to the rim misses the layup he
missed it and the rockets survive and
they've offset the Boston Celtics
[Applause]
so ecstatic for these young guys
was it perfect but you run Jason Tatum
off of the shot didn't let him get
comfortable
there's the no call
and easily if you want to say the best
win of the season for the Rockets let's
see here you're trying to get Jason
Tatum with a full head of steam and he
gets to the rim he probably thinks he
got fouled and the length at Jabar Smith
Jr makes him uncomfortable and he's not
able to finish this layup but
nonetheless this is a rookie guarding a
guy who On Any Given night can play like
the League's best player